okay today what are we doing today today
we are doing
a video that my producer McKenna is
forcing me to do we always have to have
more content I'm always told it's not
enough content Matt you need more
content what am I gonna do without my
content I'm just a piece of meat A
content producing piece of meat I'm just
going to read the email that McKenna
sent me to force me to do this video I
found this Reddit Forum debating the can
you tell me what a cat is seeing from
what is a woman after stumbling upon it
this morning the post was locked down
because it was posted to the subreddit
there was an attempt and apparently the
post violated the rules because it
didn't show an unsuccessful attempt and
I guess we should start by playing a
scene right we should play it
here it is where does the guy get a
right to say what a woman is
women only know what women are
are you a cat
no can you tell me what a cat is
actually a genuine mistake I am sorry I
even came up here
you want to tell us what a woman is and
I should also tell you a little bit of
background of that before we get to the
red reaction we were walking through San
Francisco at the time and after we had
just talked to a gender affirming quote
unquote surgeon and we're walking
through the Castro District which is
like the the gay district of San
Francisco which is already kind of
redundant to say that we talked to like
a nudist that was walking down the
street and it's Sodom and Gomorrah over
the place this guy
yeah he he comes up because according to
him we shouldn't talk to you know we
shouldn't be talking to men we should be
talking to women so that's how he got on
camera and then uh and then in that
exchange he instantly regretted his
decision I immediately regret this
decision let's check out what some
people have read it how what they make
of that uh of that moment sir sunk rum
says suncrum
sunk room
Street debate interviews tend to be
pretty lowest common denominator in
general there's not much time to prepare
gather thoughts Etc the actual person
initiating tends to have a lot more
practice and such and thus has an easy
time using rhetoric to lure their
opponents into saying dumb things to
mock there's not much intelligent
discourse as a result oftentimes growing
up I learned from people who often use
Street debating to show the superiority
of their standpoint turns out when you
show up to a fight armed and ambushed
people who aren't ready it's easy to
beat the snot out of them so to speak
yes except that in my film what is a
woman which you can watch at what is a
woman.com we try to seek out the most
informed so-called self-professed
experts in the field we sought out
people who deal with this issue every
single day and they were no more
prepared for the conversation than the
people we talked to on the street as I
said this individual we didn't Ambush
another comment says that's not exactly
the best metaphor for his side of the
argument you could accurately Define a
cat as any of the following species lion
tiger
Jaguar Puma
leopard cheetah
there's literally dozens of cats out
there and you can only think of one type
of woman no we're not
you're making my point for me yes there
are different types of cats that doesn't
mean that that cat itself doesn't have a
definition and yes there are different
types of women and when we say type what
do you mean like height weight race
ethnicity so yeah women come in all
types
but the statement women coming on all
types can't mean anything unless we know
what a woman is does it make sense that
the same company who controls half of
online retail also passively eavesdrops
on your private conversations at home
big Tech is more powerful than most
countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data it's time
to put a layer of protection between
your online activity and big Tech and
that's why I use expressvpn think about
how much of your life is on the internet
sadly every site you visit video you
watch message you send gets tracked and
data mined but when you run expressvpn
on your device the software hides your
IP address something big Tech can use to
personally identify you so especially
Beyond makes your activity harder to
trace and harder to sell to advertisers
there for expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your internet data to keep you safe
from hackers and eavesdroppers that are
on your network what I like most about
expressvpn is how easy it is to use you
can download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and that's it
you're protected and expressvpn does all
this without showing or slowing down
your connection that's why it's rated
number one VPN service by tech radar The
Verge and countless others so stop
handing all of your personal data over
to the big Tech Monopoly who Minds your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself with the VPN that I
trust to keep me safe online visit
expressvpn.com
walshyt to get three extra months free
America in Patriot says all he ever does
is go and find people he knows will slip
up how many interviews with random
people does he record before he finds
the people that will trip over their own
logic just like Stephen Crowder he
prepares himself for a certain
conversation and then hunts people down
minding their business and have not been
thinking about the topic conversation
all day these traps are such [ __ ]
well I can actually tell you like how
many people do we have to go through
before we found people that would say
incredibly stupid things we didn't have
to go through any we had to go all the
way to Africa to find people that would
just talk some common sense about this
we had to leave a lot on The Cutting
Room floor for what is a woman but it's
not because we were looking desperately
for the people who said stupid things in
fact the conversation in the editing
room was all about I don't want to cut
any of it like this should this should
be a 16-hour movie Sven Tropic says I
know this is also pedantic uh it's like
the gay marriage debate the anti-crowd
was always like why do they need
marriage they can have civil unions and
structure them however they want and
then you can turn around and say well
why does anyone then if your
classification of male female simply who
can contribute to making new people then
yes a male to female trans person is
still man but then would someone who's
sterile be it okay there yeah there's
that old Canard again
uh no the fact that there are sterile
men and infertile women that does not at
all change or even challenge the
definition of man and woman we could
accurately say
that human beings are bipedal we walk on
two legs that's an accurate statement
and if you were trying to define or
describe a human to some alien from
outer space that just landed this would
be part of your description however
there are people who have no legs
they're people who have one leg their
people have two legs but can't walk on
them you might even find people with
birth defects who have three legs it's
possible does that invalidate the
statement that human beings have two
legs
no this is the exception that proves the
rule what do we mean by that if someone
does not have two legs or is not able to
walk on two legs then you automatically
know that something is wrong because you
know that that human beings are supposed
to have two legs and be able to walk on
them the fact that we can look at the
exception we automatically know okay if
we look at this person's medical history
there's a problem here because they're
not able to do something they should be
able to do same thing with women who
can't give birth same thing with the men
who are sterile bottom line let people
be whatever they need and want to be
it's literally nearly no effort on your
part to call someone who wants to be
called a she a she it doesn't matter
otherwise this is why it's there was an
attempt to read it for him so there's an
attempt briefly to actually engage with
the conversation and then the person
realizes that they're not making any
sense and it's fruitless so then they
Retreat behind black people just let
people do what they want but let them
identify they want this is not a
question of what we let people do it's
just a question of what is what is true
what's the reality let's start with that
once we've established reality then we
could talk about what we let people do
within the context of reality I love
Lord of the Rings I've read the book so
many times I pretty much have the
timeline in the back of Return of the
King memorized I have a tattoo in Elvish
my God you dork I've been obsessed for
like 20 years if somebody came up here
on the street and said what is an elf I
would immediately go blank no freaking
clue an elf is a fictional character so
that's why it's hard to Define because
actually an elf can be I suppose
arguably whatever you want it to be
because it's just it's an invention of
the imagination and it would be hard for
anyone to tell you that you're wrong
because it is all it's all in the
imagination it's all in The Ether it's
not in reality in reality there are
limits zlg code says I don't think the
underlying logic is Holy fallacious
socially speaking is it appropriate for
men to tell women what women are no it's
the same in the reverse we can know man
is an adult male but if you've not lived
a man's life you can't tell someone what
it means to be a man like what the life
comes with the challenges and advantages
we can recite knowledge we know from
textbooks but there's a line where yes
men and women cannot tell the other what
their identity is yeah I agree with that
for the most part you're exactly right
okay so what we can say some basic
things in defining the Sexes so we can
say that a woman is an adult human
female however what is it like to be a
woman you're exactly right if you're a
woman you can't speak to that which is
also why a man can't be a woman that's
why when a male says uh I feel like I'm
a woman inside that can't mean anything
because since you're not a woman you
have no idea what the internal
experience of a woman is so there's no
way for you now whatever your internal
experience is right now if you're saying
to yourself well this is the internal
experience of a woman if you aren't a
woman you couldn't possibly know that
because you have nothing to compare it
to you have only your own experience you
have the experience of a male that's the
only experience you've ever had so
you're proving my point my answer would
be a cat is a part of the feline species
but why are we talking about species
Matt I thought we were talking about
gender
well
see this is a thing it's called a it's
called a comparison and the way that
works
Ryo hazuki 224 is that you take
something that is not exactly the same
as another thing you find similarities
okay that's but in order to have an
analogy or a comparison the two things
need to not be the same F Matt Walsh
dude is the king of incels I don't give
a sh about anything he says well that's
a good point if I'm the king of incels
then we've got we've got some issues in
the incel Kingdom if the king of incels
is driving his six kids around in an
eight passenger van and he's the king of
uh of celibate people I think there's
there's a disconnect okay we'll just
stop there that's good I think this is
good content
I don't know if it's good but it's
content
and that's all that matters
[Applause]